second débat second débat de ce sens
public on va analyser les conséquences
de la visite des manuels macron en
ukraine sur nos élections législatives
effet drapeau ou pas avant de discuter
on écoute un extrait de la déclaration
du président de la république lors de
cette conférence de presse commune on
entend aussi volodymyr zelensky
nous soutenons le statut de candidat
médias à l'adhésion à l'union européenne
pour l'ukraine ce statut sera assorti
nous l'avons dit tous ensemble d'une
feuille de route et impliquera aussi que
soit prise en compte la situation des
balkans occidentaux
et du voisinage en particulier de la
moldavie mais à travers
notre visite les changes que nous avons
une cette expression claire c'est un
geste fort rapide attendue
d'espoir et de clarté que nous voulons
envoyer à l'ukraine et à son peuple il
motore pression à des taxes mash up
d'argent nous sommes prêts à travailler
pour que notre état devienne membre à
part entière de l'union européenne ue
les ukrainiens ont déjà mérité le droit
de se mettre sur cette voie d'obtenir le
statut de candidat
émana kron à kiev mais aussi les
polémiques qui continuent autour du
front républicain les derniers sondages
à moins de trois jours du vote
jean luc mélenchon qui parle à la
jeunesse sur la plateforme twitch
beaucoup de thèmes à aborder avec mes
invités je vous les présente bérengère
bonté bonsoir bienvenue bérengère vous
êtes journaliste essayiste auteur de
cette biographie d'edouard philippe le
sioux on est aux hommes et aux éditions
de l'archipel pascal perrineau bonsoir
10 e pascal politologue professeur
émérite à sciences po j'accueille
également erwan lestrohan bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directeur conseil et
instituts de sondage au doxa et lætitia
cru pas éditorialiste politique est
évidemment rester à mes côtés on
commence par la visite bérengère bonté
du président de la république à kiev on
a parlé bien discuter des enjeux
diplomatiques en première partie donc
ont basculé un peu plus dans l'analyse
politique qu'est ce qui vient chercher
manuellement quand il ya cet effet
drapeau dont on parle tous depuis des
mois il vient chercher
on peut appeler ça l'effet drapeaux et
en l'occurrence il vient chercher
la dissipation d'un malentendu dignité
l'a peut-être ce qui restait de
compliqué à gérer
au-delà de cette image de chef de guerre
qui elle en revanche semble assez
porteuse mais c'est vrai que même si
tous les français sont pas délégués des
grands géopoliticien aujourd'hui et
géopolitologue je ne sais pas
tout le monde a senti qu'il y avait
quand même quelle qu'elle soit quel que
soit le degré de connaissance je veux
dire qu'on a de ce conflit tout mon
intention entre en transe en tout cas
entre emmanuel macron et son homologue
ukrainien et c'est très frappant de voir
cette conférence de presse où il n'a de
cesse
d'aller chercher ça jusqu'à
inviter volodymyr avance qu' à répondre
à une question à kelly n'a pas répondu
et qui est l occasion de justement
dissiper le malentendu on confère du
monde qui est qui qui évoque la lumière
poutine on en parlera peut-être
illimité mais tu n'as pas répondu et il
y revient il fait en sorte que ce que
que que celle inspirée répondre pour
justement qu'on poursuivre comme ça et
dissiper ce malentendu pascal perez qui
a forcément un effet mise en scène on
entendait tout à l'heure la déclaration
de christian jacob le président du parti
elle est en disant bon ben voilà c'est
pas devant les caméras que la diplomatie
ce fait on peut éventuellement en
discuter mais même sur le calendrier
certes on est à trois jours du second
tour des législatives mais il fallait
aussi réunir trois autres chefs d'état
avec lui est-ce qu'il ya forcément une
intention politique l'envers au bout de
ma question dans dans cette visite des
manuels match à lire le but premier de
la réunion ça n'ait pas d'influencé des
résultats des circonscriptions
législatives en france on est d'accord
mais mais ça peut avoir bien sûr un
impact mais là il a en tant que
président de l'union européenne il fait
le job et il efface j'allais dire une
première communication qui étaient
défectueuses parce que là il est dans
son rôle et il est sur le créneau sur
lequel il est resté
performant j'allais dire c'est l'image
du président habib française qui gère
bien les affaires internationales qui
est à la hauteur de la représentation du
pays à l'étranger et qui exprime tout de
même ce sur quoi on pouvait avoir
quelques doutes depuis quelques temps
particulier sur le fait qu'il fallait
épargner quelque part la russie faire
attention à la russie voilà c'est un
acte clair de solidarité avec le peuple
ukrainien et le président ukrainien et
ça j'allais dire tout le monde en avait
un peu besoin parce que peu à peu alors
que ça n'était pas du tout le cas au
début le doute pouvait s'introduire donc
là les choses sont remises j'allais dire
decker et limay il y met un certain
acharnement parce qu'il sent bien qu'il
ya un peu c'est comme l'ardoisé magique
il faut effacer il faut effacer parfois
il ya des rémanences qui peuvent qui
peuvent rester alors bien sûr tout cela
ça ne peut jamais dire qu'avantager le
camp de celles et ceux
qui le soutiennent ça remet un peu
d'autres aussi jaillir dans cette
campagne des élections législatives où
véritablement c'était de plus en plus au
ras des pâquerettes j'allais dire l'étui
telle et 8 toutes les 30 minutes vont
pas remplacer tout même une campagne
législative voyait les arguments
commençait vraiment à voler très bas ont
mobilisé un vote purement négative des
loyers venir le vote contre plutôt qu'à
vote d'adhésion sur des sur des
programmes erwan lestrohan
l'effet drapeau est ce qui peut jouer
dimanche parce que on voit bien ce que
l'impact que cela peut avoir dans une
campagne d'élection présidentielle voilà
ça ça profite directement emmanuel
macron je sais bien que mal macron est
en photo à côté d'eux de tous les
candidats ensemble tout comme jean luc
mélenchon est à côté des candidats du
cube ou marine le pen mais est-ce que
vous pensez que ça peut avoir un impact
sur le choix des électeurs dimanche de
voter pour ou contre un candidat de la
majorité présidentielle alors l'effet
drapeau faut bien avoir en tête une
chose c'est que y survient dans un
moment de grand témoin nationale ça a pu
être le cas pour george bush aux états
unis en 2001 ça a pu être le cas en 2015
pour françois hollande après les
attentats pour emmanuel macron ce
ralliement au drapeau cet effet drapeau
il a déjà eu lieu c'était à la fin du
mois de février au début du mois de mars
aujourd'hui c'est non seulement ça s'est
un peu estompée mais les français non
sans minimiser ce qui se passe en
ukraine se sont recentrés sur le
contexte national ya même un petit
risque pour emmanuel macron être absent
de france dans cette semaine stratégique
c'est qui peut donner le sentiment d'une
certaine vacance du pouvoir ou hauteur
par rapport aux préoccupations actuelles
des français dans la continuité de cet
antre législatives et présidentielles où
on a considéré que emmanuel macron était
assez peu présente arte a nommé une
première ministre d'un gouvernement
faisait plutôt profil bas sur les
réformes qu'ils allaient entrer en
vigueur à la rentrée donc je me dis
qu'il prend plutôt un risque où il prend
plutôt un risque qui sort plutôt du
contexte national il est crédité sur le
régalien la représentation de la france
à l'étranger ça c'est un point très
important et c'est un point sur lequel
il est valorisé la capacité à donner une
bonne image de la france à l'étranger
c'est une personne qui échangent avec
les chefs d'état les plus puissants donc
sacré dit emmanuel macron pour ce qui
est de la mobilisation des personnes
susceptibles de voter pour les listes de
la majorité présidentielle
on est quand même sur un autre plan
laetitia 15 images vous retenez de cette
journée où images du train ce train de
nuit ce train ukrainien qui part de
pologne pour aller vers ce pays en
guerre avec les trois chefs d'état et
chefs de gauche en nommant ensemble dans
un wagon avec des faussaires de je sais
pas on pourra dire orient-express des
faussaires de romans d'agatha christie
mais je ne dis pas ça d'un point de vue
anecdotique parce que en fait quand on
travaille dans les médias on comprend
que j'en ai et ont besoin de d'image
force pour raconter des histoires et
cette histoire du train elle a été
reprise partout et les français l'ont vu
entendu ou lu est il donc c'est une
image qui est très importante on a
compris que emmanuel macron était venu
avec un message de fraternité européenne
donc on sait que les images servent les
messages je ne suis absolument pas
d'accord avec christian jacob la
diplomatie se fait aujourd'hui
évidemment devant les caméras évidemment
à coups d'imagés et de communication
franchement je trouve qu'il est quand
même à côté de de l'époque et donc oui
bien sûr que l'elysée a mis en scène ce
déplacement notamment dans le récit avec
le suspense ira-t-il n'y at-il pas on
vous ne dit pas mais ils devraient
peut-être y aller mais jusqu'au vraiment
dernier moment les journalistes qui
étaient présents avec emmanuel macron
n'ont pas été tenus au courant et puis
ensuite il ya déjà de sécurité peut
donc ils ont bien sûr
entretenu c'est ce suspense et cetera
pour dramatiser et pour rendre encore
plus important ce déplacement mais
d'ailleurs pour la petite histoire c'est
pas très important mais la conférence de
presse dont on a vu des extraits en fait
elles avaient elles avaient été
enregistrés ces attentats n'a été
diffusée pour la première fois ça
faisait déjà une heure à peu près
qu'elles avaient été enregistrées là
aussi pour des raisons de sécurité alors
c'était assez cocasse parce que l'
agence france-presse qui étaient
présentes avaient déjà fait la dépêche
vous en savez ce que manuel macron
annoncé mais on n'avait pas encore reçu
les les images je propose à adam traduit
qui doit être en coulisses de nous
rejoindre
soir table pour pour
évaluer décortiquer les les commentaires
multiples et variés que cette visite d'
emmanuel macron à provoquer surtout du
côté des oppositions évidemment eh oui
si la position qui interroge le timing
d'une telle visite alors qu'il n'y a que
quelques jours cinq jours pour faire
campagne entre le premier et le second
tour des législatives 50 nuance de
critiquer dans les matinales radio et
télé ce matin on va faire un petit
panorama du rassemblement national à la
nuque et on va commencer avec le plus
offensif ce matin c'était jean françois
copé qui a convoqué jacques chirac rien
de moi pour rejeter vertement le
calendrier la maison brûle et emmanuel
macron ils regardent ailleurs valu
l'imaginer ce matin dans un train vers
l'ukraine comme s'il pouvait pas
attendre la semaine prochaine alors que
l'extrême gauche eto'o et et quand même
aujourd'hui hyper menaçante et et a
vocation à y rester deux jours la
roumanie la moldavie est maintenant ici
il est dans le train plus avisés qu'ils
ont raison c'est surtout que c'est d'une
légèreté incroyable voilà au
rassemblement national aussi on a eu des
objections à faire mais pas tout à fait
sur le même ton marine le pen adthink
qu'elle approuvait à la visite du chef
de l'état qui a je la cite elle n'est
pas choqué c'est légitime qu'il y aille
a discuté avec volodymyr zelensky mais
liliane lady je le redis
rien de ce que fait ou de ce que dit
emmanuel macron jamais rien
n'est dépourvu de d'arrière pensées
électoralistes tout ce qui fait tout ce
qu'il dit
un but électoraliste donc il est évident
que le choix de ce déplacement à deux
jours de l'élection du second tour
d'élections législatives à évidemment un
but électoraliste et même stratégie du
côté de la nuque avec l'eurodéputée mano
aubry qui affirme pourtant ne pas
vouloir polémiquer mais là encore il ya
un mais on peut quand même s'interroger
sur le timing il ya cinq jours de
campagne entre premier tour et le second
tour d'élection qu'on sait qu'à une
visée électorale pour faire il faudra
pour vous connaissez voilà l'effet
drapeau essayer de réunir le pays hier
une cause voilà l'effet drapeau dont
vous avez parlé à l'instant dans le même
camp alexis corbière débuté la france
insoumise tout nouvellement réélu à lui
enfoncer le clou c'est le peuple
ukrainien que monsieur macron veut
t'aider ou sa propre équipe et son parti
actuellement en difficulté que répond le
camp d'emmanuel macron ses partisans il
ya les critiques elles sont bien entendu
balayé à part les partisans d' emmanuel
macron exemple avec le ministre chargé
de l'europe clément bonne également
candidat en difficulté aux législatives
à paris est ce qu'une fois dans cette
campagne chez monsieur corbières on peut
avoir un peu de hauteur de vue de
dignité quand même prendre la république
n'est pas candidat aux législatives il a
été élu le 24 avril on nous reproche
tout et son contraire pas y aller assez
tôt y aller trop tard est ce que par
respect par dignité par engagement
européen je sais que ça gêne un peu la
france insoumise on peut alors que eux
ont dit que l'ania poutine devait être
un allié de la france que l'agression
russe était du pipeau je cite jean luc
mélenchon ici même bon
l'argument qui justifie la date de ce
déplacement pour le ministre chargé de
l'europe est candidat c'est que la
présidence française de l'union
européenne touche à sa fin que nous
sommes à une semaine d'un nouveau sommet
européen et qu'en plus de ça il a fallu
coordonner les agendas de trois
responsables européens de premier plan
noté que clément bonne profite bien sûr
de la question pour tacler les
accointances passées de jean luc
mélenchon avec vladimir poutine alors qu
à trois jours du second tour la macro ni
agite un chiffon rouge qui vire à
l'écarlate face à l'éventualité d'une
victoire de la lippe merci à mes filles
tv effectivement erwan lestrohan ce
chiffon ou gentil mélenchon
ils marchent ou presque ils marchent
d'abord et aussi si oui auprès de quels
électeurs alors c'est tout l'enjeu pour
pour emmanuel macron c'est vrai que la
majorité des second tour qui auront lieu
dimanche une sonde aux épaules des
oppositions entre la nuit passée
ensemble ses 271 second tour donc
nécessairement emmanuel macron a intérêt
à insister sur ce positionnement
politique d'ensemble qui est moins
radical que la nuit ps mais aussi moins
radicale nécessairement que le
rassemblement national et de bénéficier
de cette centralité politique pour
bénéficier au mieux des reports de vote
des électeurs de droite quand il est
opposé à la gauche et des reports de
vote des électeurs de gauche quand il
est opposé à l'extrême évidemment se
poser en rempart face aux extrêmes ça
peut être un facteur de mobilisation de
son électorat en revanche ça peut aussi
susciter l'animosité des forces
politiques qui sont présentés comme des
extrêmes ce qu'on n'entende pas
vraisemblablement tous les sens pendant
et sympathisants de la du ps mais aussi
ceux du rassemblement national ni
bérengère bonté qu'est-ce qui va se
jouer effectivement dans ses 271
circonscription c'est un vote contre en
fait c'est à dire plutôt à votre contre
jean luc mélenchon contre emmanuel
macron qu'un vote d'adhésion pour les
programmes c'est un peu ce que disait
pascal perrineau tout à l'heure ça on
est
évidemment
on a beaucoup évoqué tous ces derniers
mois à vrai dire le
l'énorme rejet que que provoquait
président la république dans l'opinion
et c'est vrai qu'il ya dieu sait que
jean luc mélenchon est clivant mais je
veux dire emmanuel macron bien que réélu
et donc sa majorité a attiré
effectivement beaucoup de beaucoup de
méfiance beaucoup de 2,2 et génère donc
un vote
effectivement qui n'est pas forcément en
trade en tout cas autour de lui des
votes qui sont pas qu'ils sont pas des
votes d'adhésion et donc c'est là où sa
devise c'est là où c'est très difficile
de faire des prévisions et j'aimerai pas
être sanders attend demain je ne suis
pas mais et c'est ces gens on en est
même à il ya quelques voilà ces
dernières heures qui le sociologue hervé
le bras ce par exemple qui estime mai
mais encore une fois c'est très
difficile à prouver que qu'on a
probablement
fortement sous-estimé le les chances du
camp macron et lui
prédit un
groupe ensemble de 345 élus se basant
sur un calcul de séchage monde en fait
basé sur un calcul
d'une départementale de 2015 alors
évidemment les scrutins n'ont rien à
voir même si avec une forte abstention
avec également trois blocs gauche droite
extrême droite et où ses skis exactement
ce qui vient d'être dit il il dit le
candidat du centre attire le fasse a
condamné ses droits face avec sa droite
attire la neige c'était le scénario qui
était dans la coulisse de l'elysée au
tout départ un jojo je vous l'avais dit
sur ce plateau d'ailleurs ils étaient
convaincus qu'ils auraient une majorité
plus large qu'en 2017 alors ensuite il
ya eu une petite fille brigitte et quand
ils ont vu bien sûr la nuque la
progression et puis et puis les
résultats du premier tour met vraiment
en amont du scrutin s'était c'était en
tout cas le pari de leasing je pense que
larry va me suivre et qu'on voit les
projections en sièges du dernier sondage
ruisseau d'eau que ça vous que vous
proposez qui est vraiment très
intéressant ya beaucoup de questions
qu'on va on va s'appuyer dessus la dent
dans le temps qui nous reste dans ce
dans ce débat projection en sièges donc
on voit le
selon votre travail 252 292 pour
ensemble un jour et aux essentiels 179 à
225 pour la nuque 42,62 pour lr udi 25
49 pour le rassemblement national
extrême droite là on est on y est pas au
345 donc par la loi loin de là même nom
mais on est très en deçà en fait
finalement le camp la majorité absolue à
l'assemblée nationale est à 289 sièges
c'est finalement parmi les hypothèses
les moins probables dans notre
fourchette aujourd'hui ça ne dis pas que
c'est impossible ça dit que c'est une
solution qui est moins probable et qu'on
se dirige plutôt vers un scénario qui
serait non seulement une majorité
relative mais aussi une opposition de
gauche extrêmement importante qui
pourrait avoir 180 à 220 sièges donc à
un niveau très important qui dépasserait
le groupe l'est républicain comme
principal groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale une comme une
reconfiguration des forces en vigueur
aussi et on voit ça montre que la
tectonique des plaques qu'on a observés
au soir du premier tour a quand même
modifier la structure est quand même
susceptible de modifier la structure de
l'assemblée nationale et ça montre aussi
tout l'enjeu stratégique pour emmanuel
macron qui peut survenir dans les
prochains jours selon qu'il dispose
d'une majorité absolue ou relative et
souvent ils nouveaux équilibres qui
pourraient devoir service ça on va se
projeter évidemment là là là dedans
pascal perrineau mais quand même dans
cette courte très courte campagne
d'entre deux tours des législatives
on peut avoir le sentiment que c'était
manuel mâcon qui donne le tempo est ce
que vous vous êtes pas on dit que c'est
souvent très important en politique est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça oui
pour l'instant dans l'impression
qu'après une grande période de faiblesse
de communication extrêmement brouillonne
je pense à son entretien avec la presse
quotidienne régionale je pense encore à
l'intervention sur le tarmac d'orly etc
on a l'impression que les chats pour
vous c'était pas c'était pas bien joué
non non je prends pas que c'était de se
donner un signe de fébrilité oui ça
donne aux signes de fébrilité un peu
d'affolement
la symbolique n'est pas la bonne bon
voila fr de cette très incohérent mais
toute la politique n'est pas que de la
communication et heureusement mais on
voit dans vos données dans les données
de doxa on voit tout de même que voilà
même si c'est le moins probable le haut
de votre fourchette et c'est la majorité
absolue le haut de la fourchette de
nubes n'atteint pas le bas de la
fourchette
d'ensemble et ça c'est très important
c'est à dire que là pour l'instant la
perspective d'une épaisse qui bouleverse
un bouleversera est complètement parce
que c'est elle qui aurait la majorité
relative c'est impossible c'est
impossible aujourd'hui et on voit pas
très bien dans les derniers jours ce qui
pourrait bouleverser
bouleverser ce scénario donc pour
l'instant on est toujours dans la même
et pur la majorité absolue c'est pas le
scénario le plus probable mais c'est pas
un scénario impossible les 345 là je
crois que véritablement ça n'est pas
raisonnable de situer ensemble à un
aussi haut niveau la majorité relative
mais une fois de plus on revient quelle
majorité relative si c'est une majorité
relative il leur manque sept huit
députés mais ça sera facile j'allais
dire d'aller les chercher en revanche au
cas par cas en fonction des cas par cas
puis les députés ils ont leur quant à
soi sur certains projets on trouvera des
divers gauche sur d'autres projets ils
trouveront des des divers droite et même
des gens du lr ou ne sera plus compliqué
mais emmanuel macron va réapprendre un
peu
prison qualité très bien pour lui la
culture du compromis parlementaire voilà
ça sera ça la nouvelle méthode vraiment
la nouvelle méthode au delà du discours
ah bon et puis on peut aussi imaginer un
scénario beaucoup plus difficile il y
manque 20 25 qui se retrouve avec une
majeure et l'ati majorité relative mais
tombent dans les 260 ça fait 29 députés
allaient chercher là ça devient très
compliqué et on passe peut-être un autre
scénario c'est à dire un accord
institutionnel avec un groupe pour
pouvoir garantir que ça serait sans
doute à la cour divers gauche il est dit
la gauche arrivait à avoir un groupe ce
qui n'est pas le scénario plus près
alors sur cette question de deux
majorités
présidentielles de majorité absolue ou
non il ya aussi un élément intéressant à
un espoir dans votre sondage c'est vous
avez demandé que souhaitent les français
finalement et alors ça ça peut sembler
paradoxal 63% veulent une majorité pour
ensemble mais 70 % ne souhaitent pas une
majorité absolue devançant la ccl la
chambre un trouve c'est un peu la cendre
introuvable c'est la caractéristique de
cette élection où les français vont
arbitrer un match dont il ne souhaite
pas de vainqueur c'est la majorité
relative quand on leur demandait ce que
vous souhaitez que la majorité
présidentielle dispose de la marche et
de la majorité absolue 25% nous disent
oui on est en retraite mais quand on
leur demandait ce que vous souhaitez que
la nuque ps dispose de la majorité
absolue ils sont 32% à nous dire oui
donc c'est pas non plus une hypothèse
qui les séduit ce qui les séduit le plus
proportionnellement c'est 38 % de
français qui sont favorables à une
majorité relative et c'est même une
hypothèse qui dépasse les 50% chez les
électeurs de premier tour d'anne hidalgo
de fabien roussel de yannick jadot de
valérie pécresse de marine le pen donc
cette culture parlementaire de
discussion qui pourrait s'installer qui
ferait penser au quinquennat au deuxième
quinquennat au début du deuxième
quinquennat de françois mitterrand et
michel rocard j'ai vu aussi le 49-3
multiplier mais qui pourrait être une
solution finalement verticale et qui
conviendra aux français on rappelle en
quelques mots pascal perrineau 49,3 la
règle a changé quand même en plus
utilisée quand elle est de change avant
on pouvait l'utiliser à foison michel
rocard l'avait utilisé 28 fois le record
man tout catégorique maintenant c'est
terminé on peut l'utiliser qu'une fois
par session donc voilà plus le budget
donc voyez c'est extrêmement restreint
c'est extrêmement et saint leu leu le
paradoxe angers rebond de 2,2 ce vote on
va voir on sera peut-être surpris
dimanche c'est que peut y avoir une
poussée à gauche une nuque puissante à
l'assemblée et un emmanuel macron qui
gouverne un peu plus à droite contraint
et forcé bleus qui va probablement qui
par la force des choses et au fil de
cette campagne et est parti vers la
droite souvenez-vous que l'entre-deux
tours de la présidentielle son premier
réflexe est d'aller à marseille et
parler à la gauche et par les
écologistes da là son premier réflexe
c'est celle inverse c'est de s'exprimer
clairement vers là les choses sont
relativement claires et maintenant qu'il
est acquis qu'il y aura une gauche
puissante de façon inespérée pour eux
évidemment ça va ça va le déporter dans
le vert la drogue sa fleur de mots une
gauche puissant édifice est divisé en
plusieurs numériquement et peut-être
ensuite divisés autrement oui parce que
chaque partie cela ne peut espérer avoir
un gros ce parlement un groupe à
l'assemblée et à gauche très très
fragile déjà la première et nrj
ont parlé dlr évidemment qu ici s'il
veut des accords au coup par coup sûr
certains textes il va bien falloir
qu'ils se positionnent clairement dans
une position acceptable pour eux on n'a
pas parlé du groupe horizon et du groupe
modem mais vu la place un peu centrales
que sont en train d'acquérir ces deux
personnalités françois bayrou et et
edouard philippe il va bien falloir là
aussi donné quelques gages donc donc là
c'est plus tout à fait la même histoire
la rigueur budgétaire la dette etc il va
falloir sans doute chez moi si vous avez
la réponse est pas une colle mais est ce
que on sait quelles sont les prévisions
en nombre de sièges pour le modem d'un
côté où ils ont deux jours d'une
cinquantaine pour le modem entre 40 et
50 et autour de 20 25 je pense pour
horizon ça donne à peu près ces
tendances là mais ça montre déjà que la
république en marche n'est pas
majoritaire quoi qu'il arrive vous est à
elle seule qu'elle a besoin d'eux un
manant certaine renaissance et sur le
l'homogénéité de l'union de la gauche
qui va avoir aussi en terme de
calendrier c'est quand 2024 les
prochaines élections sur les élections
européennes qui peuvent introduire qu'il
va être facteur de divisions entre les
différentes forces de gauche entre les
insoumis le parti socialiste notamment
alors je voudrais qu'on discute un peu
ce front républicain c'est un thème un
peu récurrent cette semaine mais c'est
intéressant parce que on a l'impression
que c'est toujours pas aussi claires au
sein de
gouvernement écouter les nuances du
front républicain la première ministre
elisabeth bornes hier soir et son
ministre chargé de l'europe clément
bonne c'était ce matin sur france info
quand on a face au front national du
rassemblement national des candidats qui
insulte nos policiers qui sont ambigus
sur la laïcité et qui sont en connivence
avec la russie non nous n'appelons pas à
voter pour eux moi je ne voterai jamais
pour l'extrême droite et quand l'extrême
droite un adversaire je vote pour
l'adversaire de l'extrême droite c'est
beaucoup plus clair chez clément bonne
là aussi je m'approche je m'appuie sur
votre sondage vous avez posé la question
aux électeurs démarrera à tous les
électeurs de chacun des candidats après
ans il met notamment nous ce qui nous a
intéressé les électeurs des manuels
macron qu'est-ce qui souhaite à terme de
consignes de vote 20 % souhaitent que
les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle appelle à voter nul en
cas évidemment deux duels face aux
arènes en est dans cette logique de
front républicain 12 % quand même 10
voter et rennes et 52% c'est le premier
chiffre qui s'est affichée refuse toute
consigne de vote pascal perrineau ce
barrage républicain on le voit
s'effriter élection après élection la
nouvelle
tripartition de notre échiquier
politique est ce qu'elle ne rend pas
finalement obsolète
le mieux ce front républicain il est
toute façon lézarder lézarder depuis de
très longues années
pour beaucoup de lecteurs ça n'a plus de
sens et puis en plus ça c'est un front
républicain qui se dédouble en un double
front puisqu'il y a maintenant deux
radicalités certaine manière qui peuvent
être à tord ou à raison c'est pas le
problème considéré comme menaçant les
valeurs de la république etc c'est à la
fois contre la gauche de la gauche
contre la gauche radicale et contre la
droite radicale 1 alors on voit bien les
utilisations un peu politique à quoi ça
peut mener parce qu'on se présente dans
la position avantageuse
en effet de l'extrême centre qui rejette
les deux familles radical de paris
l'autre donc il ya des utilisations en
effet de ce double refont républicain
mais on voit bien qu'entre ils ne sont
pas d'accord madame bord n'est pas
d'accord avec monsieur bonne
madame bornes en effet dit que bah voilà
les électeurs
d'ensemble pour pratiquer éventuellement
le refus de choisir et et le vote blanc
ou voilà alors que clément bonne mais
attention clément bonne il est dans une
position difficile dans une
circonscription la de gauche et donc
ses électeurs est effectivement erwan
lestrohan ce chiffre quand même 52%
d'électeurs des mâles macron disant veux
pas de consignes de vote oui c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs de le noter un on
sait que de toute façon les électeurs
tiennent pas forcément compte des
consignes de vote qui sont donnés par
les candidats mais en tout cas ce que ça
montre c'est que le candidat n'est pas
attendue dans une posture face à
l'extrême droite ou face à ce qu'il
présente comme l'extrême gauche alors
que lui-même les présente comme des
extrêmes ce cas c'est paradoxal par
contre sur ce front républicain qui
s'est atténuée je tiens quand même à
modérer un peu tout ça parce que
finalement ce qu'on a vu à la
présidentielle c'est que au soir du
deuxième tour l'écart entre emmanuel
macron et marine le pen était un peu
plus important que ce que mesurer les
sondages qui a laissé envisager qu'il
existerait maintenant un espèce de ce
qu'on pourrait appeler un front
républicain de dernière minute versez
pas un front républicain qui s'impose au
soir du premier tour on tels que ça a pu
être le cas le 21 avril 2002 mais plutôt
un homme si ça n'est pas un réflexe une
idée qui fait son chemin au fur et à
mesure de l'entre-deux tours et qui se
décide le dernier jour d'eau qui peut y
avoir quand même ce rebond on voit bien
par exemple que les électeurs d'anne
hidalgo fabien roussel yannick jadot
sont les plus prompts à souhaiter un
vote d'opposition au rassemblement
national à la différence de ceux de jean
luc mélenchon qui préfère qu'il n'y a
pas de consignes mais c'est vrai que le
principe du front républicain est telle
qu'il a existé à plein et jouer à plein
en 2002 est relativement détériorer et
ça rejoint ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure un peu plus tôt dans débat sur
la possibilité finalement d'une majorité
absolue par ce réflexe de regroupement
autour du candidat qui est le plus
centriste dans chacun des des duels on
va parler de jean luc mélenchon
maintenant laëtitia il a pris le parti
d'interpeller directement les jeunes
pour les appeler à déplacer aux ions de
dimanche il le fait évidemment en allant
sur leur support favori oui au mont se
parlent thomas il doit être sûr twitch
voilà cette plateforme très prisé des
jeunes alors c'est une spéciale
élections législatives bien sûr il est
en train de présenter son programme et
bien sûr il surtout il surligne les
mesures à destination des jeunes comme
la suppression de deux parcours sup à 70
ans finalement le doyen de la
présidentielle et celui qui a mieux
compris le mix le mix médiatique c'est à
dire que il manie aussi bien les médias
traditionnels et des sur le plateau du
20 heures il était dans le studio de rtl
et puis il va aussi régulièrement sur
youtube sur tous les supports numériques
très prisé encore une fois des 15 25 ans
notamment sur tik tok c'est un des seuls
qui sait utiliser tik tok avec peut-être
emmanuel macron et donc ils multiplient
les messages à destination des jeunes
électeurs bon alors ni dont il y en a
qui disent mais comment je pourrais bien
mélenchon comme limite du cap à 2,8 a
écrit premier ministe mélenchon comment
je fais comment je vais commencer
et pas difficile à reconnaître ya
dessous d'accord je vais comme on peut
voter comme victoire mais 12 et le 19
juin on va
voter pour la victoire pratique toc pour
ceux qui connaissent et des petites
vidéos comme ça avec de la musique il en
poste vraiment très régulièrement alors
bien sûr son pari il a toujours un peu
le même temps c'est un petit côté père
fouettard là quand même la wii mais ça
crée aussi son personnage finalement
vous savez thomas en communication on
conseille toujours de ne pas trop
s'éloigner de sa nature profonde donc
c'est la nature de jean-luc mélenchon et
donc ils exploitent et basson paris
c'est bien sûr de contourner cette
faible réserve de voix et le c est donc
de convaincre les abstentionnistes et
les jeunes sont très abstentionnistes on
l'avait rappelé sur ce plateau un
sondage ipsos offs à sopra steria donne
taux d'abstention chez les 18-24 de 69 %
et 71 % chez les 25 34 ans ça c'était
les chiffres du haut du congo alors est
ce que cette efficace cette
communication annonce
si on regarde ces chiffres géo dire non
mais la politique n'est pas gravé dans
le marbre et tout peut encore évoluer en
tout cas le calcul de mélenchon n'est
pas idiot 1 mais il le fait un peu
maladroitement on l'avait passé sur ce
plateau effectivement dans son interview
au 20h de france 2 il était un peu
agressif il a continué dans
l'agressivité 1 vous voyez quand on est
voilà un âne naturel est difficile de
sang de s'en éloigner et le dis par
exemple dans l'émission quotidien sur
sur tmc il a harangué comme ça les
jeunes en disant bouge toi mon pote
bouge toi un peu en demandant aux filles
aussi de se bouger encore plus parce que
sinon ils éréac allait arriver donc je
suis encore très doué dans la
psychologie des vingtenaires mais je
n'ai pas l'impression que cette méthode
soit très efficace et c'est pas le seul
à s'adresser aux jeunes évidemment
emmanuel macron est assez actif lui
aussi oui avec plus ou moins de brio là
aussi en témoigne la dernière vidéo
postée par les jeunes avec macron qui a
été très vite retiré vous allez
comprendre pourquoi voici un petit
extrait
non
[Musique]
mais c'est possible
voilà c'est tout les risques si la nuque
passé puis dans ses envois de textos il
y a le jeune qui dit vivement mon
week-end de trois jours à marrakech pas
sûr que ce soit le bon message un canton
veut faire revenir les jeunes à la
politique et pourtant deux ans après
vraiment près deux ans non un an après
après après le dernier confinement
rappelez vous ce que emmanuel macron
avait dit il y avait un boulevard 1 pour
les jeunes pour faire revenir les jeunes
à la politique emmanuel macron habile
ses mots il avait dit c'est dur d'avoir
20 ans en 2020 je ne donnerai jamais
leçon aux jeunes car ce sont eux qui
vivent le plus grand sacrifice et quand
on voit aujourd'hui la communication
politique à destination des jeunes il ya
encore beaucoup beaucoup de trains mais
angers remonte c'est l'un des paradoxes
de cette année électorale le doyen des
candidats à la présidentielle et celui
qui qui attire le plus le vote des
jeunes même s'il ya eu évidemment
beaucoup d'abstention là on l'a vu au
premier tour déjà y en eut en les
engageant comme il le fait là et puis
quelques jours pas sûr que ça avec nick
qu'il en ait un qui s'en convaincre plus
mais c'est vrai que jean luc mélenchon
tient on sent dans cette dernière
campagne qui était enfin cette dernière
dernière dernière campagne de
d'amusement une espèce de d'excitation
yahia c'est sans doute un peu
vertigineux ce qui attend jean luc
mélenchon après oui parce qu'on rappelle
qu'il est se présente le tir il ne sera
pas à l'assemblée il ne sera pas à
matignon comme on peut le dire donc
donc en fait il y a un plaisir
effectivement à jouer donc ça s'est
passé par le cio logram c'est affirmant
qu'ils savaient qu'ils s'amusent avec
tout ce à quoi je crois dans le vote des
jeunes il ya un élément dont on n'a pas
parlé je suis bien incapable de vous
dire les fées qui va voir mais c'est la
canicule de séjour s'il on va on va il
ya une douzaine je crois de départements
aux canicules rouge qui veut dire au
moins trois nuits et surtout que la
température ne redescend pas ça veut
dire trois nuits si vous comptez bien ça
nous amène week-end je suis sincèrement
alors entre emmanuel macron qu'est ce
qui est à la guerre mais qui va revenir
je vais dire ça c'est quand même alors
de nature probablement attiré plutôt un
électorat et à motiver un électorat ou
des abstentionnistes plutôt de gauche et
écologistes mais est ce que ça peut pas
mobiliser cette jeunesse dont on a
tellement dit à raison qu'elle était
quand même très très mobilisé sur ce
sujet là qu'elle avait vidé tous les
envoyer sur a bien sûr
que je me pose si les nuggets ont un peu
malin
alors je voudrais qu'on décide de dire
du ps ou nuls mais je crois que
l'académie française a répondu à un
confrère de 2
deux publics de lcp la chaîne nationale
et la lac erie française a dit on dit
nul voila mondy j voilà donc moi je vais
dire nulle d'accord jusqu'à jusqu'à ce
que cette coalition dur on verra bien
aller à d'autres je redeviens un peu
plus sérieux on va reprendre un chiffre
celui de l'abstention airways france et
c'est intéressant vous avez estimé
l'abstention pour ce dimanche et vous
l'estimez au même niveau qu'au premier
tour c'est à dire 53% c'est ça c'est ça
elle pourra atteindre 53 % ce qui ne
serait pas le record de la vème
république comme ça a été le cas au
premier tour parce qu'on était à 57% au
deuxième tour en 2017 mais qui était un
deuxième tour plutôt de confirmation là
c'est un peu préoccupant parce qu'il
reste quand même beaucoup d'inconnues et
puis ça montre un peu c'est jupitérien
que finalement le régime de la vème
république est devenue très présidentiel
et que les français boudent un peu c'est
cette élection législative et peut-être
ne se rendent pas compte du
contre-pouvoir puissant que peut être
l'assemblée nationale donc une
abstention forte une abstention
évidemment très typé sociologiquement
plus forte chez les plus jeunes chez les
plus modestes est plus importante chez
les français les plus insérés
socialement les les plus âgés voire même
les 60 ans et plus donc on est sur des
des niveaux préoccupants d'abstention
est justement ces jeunes qui ne devrait
pas voter ça montre un peu tout
l'intérêt aussi pour jean luc mélenchon
est la nièce de les mobiliser parce que
si ensemble dispose de réserves de voix
dans le corps électoral est peu suscité
les réserves de voix auprès de la droite
et de la gauche modérée les réserves de
voix pour la nuit baisse pour la nuque
pardon
je suis super
côté
les réserves de voix pour la nuit elle
se situe finalement en dehors du corps
électoral de dimanche dernier et ses cv
alors qui va voir tu vas falloir aller
cher alors justement c'est intéressant
si on essaye de d'imaginer des leviers
de mobilisation de dernière minute vous
avez dit pourquoi pas la canicule le le
sentiment d'urgence climatique dans la
jeunesse est ce que vous en voyez
d'autres vous pascal perrineau non
personne penser qu'on va rester sur une
construction de ce genre d'abstention
élevé qui aura les mêmes
caractéristiques leur foule dit c'est à
dire une jeunesse extrêmement touchés
par l'abstention parce que toute une
partie de la jeunesse
s'interrogent de plus en plus sur l'acte
même du vote et de l'élection donc ça va
ça va loin et 2g en quelques heures ou
en quelques jours
cette réticence par rapport à l'acte
électoral parce que vous disiez à juste
titre toute une série de jeunes étaient
dans la rue sur le changement climatique
ça ne veut pas du lieu pas du tout dire
que il trouve la même légitimité à aller
voter vous voyez donc ce sont des jeunes
qui parfois peuvent être extrêmement
différents la manifestation n'est pas le
premier pas de la mobilisation
électorale dans la jeunesse et puis
méfions nous de parler de la jeunesse
c'est politiquement les jeunesses il
faudrait dire et bien sûr la jeunesse ça
veut rien dit parce qu'indépendamment du
fait qu'ils ont à peu près tous le même
âge de leurs artères rien ne les
rassemble entre les jeunes et ils sont
nombreux de milieux populaires en bas de
la hiérarchie des diplômes qui vont
voter massivement pour marine le pen et
le rassemblement national regarder les
scores vous disiez tout à l'heure sur
les 25 34 ans ces jeunes là qui sont ou
du mal à rentrer sur le marché du
travail etc pour là c'est une jeunesse
bien particulière dont on parle très peu
mais qui vote massivement
rn1 la jeunesse éduquée balle vote tout
de même très éduquer insérer venant de
milieux favorisés elle vote avant tout
ensemble et puis vous avez une jeunesse
qui est plus intermédiaire de lycéens
d'étudiants qui parfois en effet
considérables voilà que les études salle
en face à leur donnera pas forcément
l'accès au marché du travail et cela ils
votent plutôt en faveur de jean-luc
mélenchon mais c'est j'allais dire pas
grand-chose quantitativement c'est 30%
le sait jeunesse c'est ce qu'ils vont
voter j'allais dire j'étais pas d'accord
avec vous s'il ya bien un point commun
entre tous ces jeunes c'est l'abstention
donc aussi on peut les considérer moi je
trouve comme une catégorie électorale
parce que il y à sept jeunes sur 10 qui
ne vont pas voter et il faut quand même
prendre à bras le corps ce problème
parce qu'ils se reconnaissent dans ses
anticipations
contestataires que dans une
participation conventionnel que comme le
vin fait cesser c'est tout l'enjeu des
saillies ça va avec les manifestations
contre selongey dans toutes les
politiques a évidemment pour nous pour
réanimer un peu la vie démocratique avec
les 25-34 ans - ils sont jeunes mais
enfin ils sont quand même adulte 1 c'est
pas non plus ils sortent pas du nid donc
c'est c'est leur jeu il est urgent c'est
pour demain et c'est aujourd'hui aussi
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce
débat